la visita de nancy pelosi ha
desencadenado las mayores maniobras
militares de la historia en una zona el
estrecho de formosa donde no han
escaseado hasta esta semana contaba tres
grandes crisis china ha lanzado 11
misiles a aguas taiwanesa es una medida
que no había tomado en casi 20 años y
tampoco es habitual que sus barcos
crucen la línea media que funciona como
frontera oficiosa taiwán ha denunciado
ese bloqueo de facto que está
entorpeciendo el transporte marítimo y
que ha obligado a varias aerolíneas a
redirigir sus vuelos los lamentos
también han llegado desde japón que
asegura que cinco misiles chinos han
caído dentro de su zona de exclusión
económica precisamente hoy china ha
cancelado una reunión que iba a mantener
su ministro de exteriores con el de
japón de la razón más probable es el
escrito del g7 y del que japón forma
parte en el que se acusa a pekín de
utilizar como pretexto la visita de
pelosi para incrementar su actividad
militar en la zona ha respondido china
que sus medidas son razonables y
legítimas ha acusado a eeuu de causar la
crisis actual y ha dicho que nadie puede
sorprenderse porque ya había avisado
varias veces de las consecuencias del
viaje de pelosi la última vez fue en la
charla presidencial que mantuvieron la
semana pasada xi jinping y joe biden